between now an election
that america is a freedom-loving nation
and america is a nation of faith
[Music]
and as we travel across this land the
sweetest words the president and i ever
hear when someone is saying
[Music]
and we hear a lot
and so i would just say if you're
if you have a mind that bend the knee or
bow the head from time to time
that'd be a good time to do it and over
the next 12 days
i'd encourage you to pray with
confidence
claim those ancient words that americans
have clung to
through much more challenging times than
we could possibly imagine
the americans who cleared the forest
that settled this state the americans
who've been fought from the wars
endured the great challenges in our
nation
those ancient words that if his people
who are called by his name will humble
himself
and pray and turn
he'll do like he's always done in the
long and storied
history of this nation he'll hear from
heaven
and he'll heal this laugh
[Music]
[Applause]
under god indivisible with liberty
and justice for all so pray for america
great for all
of the american people it will make a
difference
and i leave here today with renewed
confidence
grateful for your support grateful for
your attendance here today
more confident than ever that we are
just 12 days away from a great victory
all across michigan and all across
america
and i just know if all of us do all that
we need to do
between now and election day
we're going to make michigan and america
stronger and safer than ever before
we're going to make michigan
and america more prosperous than you
could possibly imagine
we're going to make michigan and america
more united
than ever before and it was john james
in the united states
and eric asaki in a new republican
majority
in the house with president
donald trump in the white house for four
more years
and with god's help we will make america
great again
[Music]
again thank you all very much
god bless you god bless america and
let's
go get it done michigan
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one key
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
going down
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
cheese
[Music]
from
[Music]
fast enough
[Music]
so many times
[Music]
it must be
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]